[Music]
uh uh don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate say hey babe hey bab hey babe
hey bab heyab hey bab what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
hey babe now listen to me okay s is not
here for this week and next week and
then I believe he's coming back the week
after I know people get upset and they
say I'm not going to watch it unless s's
on I'm not going to watch it unless the
both you are on why are you guys even
doing episodes if you're not both going
to be there I hear it I hear what you're
saying and I'm going to be honest I'm
not listening because the reason why
we're doing the episodes is because we
like to do it we need to do it and we
want to keep consistency and there are
times when one of us is out like a s is
out where we get the opportunity to have
a fun guest come in and then just sit
here and take the place of one of us and
get new energy in the show and see if
maybe hey bab will evolve into one day
for example today the Chris and kraton
Colin Quinn show yeah Katon Colin as
he's known in the streets CR that was a
long intro it was long winded I know the
show it was long winded because okay our
first topic crinkle cut versus steak
fries I'd say crinkle cut that was taste
that's taste bud T they already told me
yeah this is hey babe where we usually
sing an intro song you do what's your
favorite song hey babe what what's your
favorite song of all time my favorite
song is Hey babe I'm GNA Leave You by Le
Zeppelin oh that is a good song speaking
of Le Zeppelin I saw pink last night I
got you hey babe what you went to see
pink you traitor Sam was right next door
at the Hulu theater and you went to see
pink no it Sam was Saturday while I was
in Columbus Ohio who whoa the state
capital right what's the capital of
Minnesota uh duth St Paul oh Jesus what
state Minneapolis what's that what state
is cron in Nebraska hey what's the
capital of Nebraska Omaha Linc linc yeah
you got
it um I went I just went and got coffee
from Olstein the Danish Bakery that we
like oh we like that Place shout out to
Danish but that was pretty considerate
to get yourself coffee none of us World
sitting here with nothing I asked I
asked pimp if he wanted who knows when
ven tea shows up why wouldn't you have
texted me and said hey kle we know you
like tea and danishes you like why would
you have done that because I figured you
were at bubblies but you know what the
problem is the problem is not you the
problem is every if I had a podcast no
it's not because every morning show been
like this I've been yelling at every
morning show from Opie and Anthony
Howard Stern since I started you can
look at the footage and and I always say
the same thing the only show that really
knew how to treat morning guests what
really treated you like I mean it was
amazing Martha Stewart of course the
best she had a morning show you show up
they go okay we have this this they'd
bring you a whole thing a girl would
come in with the insurance go this is
this here's a drink everything was set
up perfectly right it's beautiful I
never got a chance to do the Martha
Stewart show but I did do Howard Stern
but my point is where that's not what
it's
about oh wait hold on if you take your
glasses off I'll take mine off no I'll
put mine on I don't really need it right
now speaking of which by leg like that
my my my first move I've been talking to
pimp I've been torturing pimp about my
hour for like a long time and uh by the
way pimp now officially what the Unseen
hand of Show Business yes like um of
Comedy let's just say comedy you know
why cuz he has the power cuz he's not
doing it for the money he wants money
like anybody else he's probably like
please don't don't say that he wants
money but he's not in it for the money
the Unseen power passion which is very
similar to Pink oh I'm
sorry by the way you're talking to one
of the few people that actually saw pink
in concert so I can have this
conversation you saw pink yeah at the
Brockley Center like six years ago my
wife wanted to go see pink so go ahead
you start then I'll add my little
comments about pink you're talking to
one of the few people had seen her well
pink well I mean she sells a lot of
ticket I mean she's sold out tour pink
well of course she's pink yeah it's pink
all the shows what's her real name we
don't know I think it's Alicia right
Alicia Keys you're right Alicia Keys um
Alicia Alicia Beth Moore oh um she uh
the the the show the show is
unbelievable she flies all around um I I
didn't eat last night but I did have
three vodka sodas so I'm feeling a
little hung over a little drowsy right
but that's nothing Pimp's been he's
exhausted too we're all tired here
listen first of all you just how could
you just cut off the pink conversation
here's your problem I literally said the
one person in comedy that's ever seen
pink and you go and pink was great she
flies around but I'm a little hung over
but so's pimp what's your problem I my
problem what is your problem my
problem it's just new blood pressure
medicine well I saw her fly around too
now you know she broke her back in
Berlin like 10 years ago doing those
Highwire acts she does does like a whole
acrobatic show she's singing it's really
great she's singing she's flying across
the audience like dangerous acrobatics
and is like a thousand little girls in
soccer moms singing along with her and
me and me and you right she off this
this happened live on the show yeah this
was in Germany she she broke her back
this is how I've never seen this because
this is how how she this is how she ends
the show and it's unbelievable the way
she ends she sings um her famous song
what's her famous song she has a few
famous songs oh [__] with the guy from
fun that was in front of the whole show
right no she fell off the thing yeah
Jesus Christ she fell off the wire and
broke her back and she oh my God yeah no
she um this show Germany yeah and and
it's amazing then I didn't know that how
she still gets back up and did it all
years later that's the key the key if
you bomb and stand up you got to get
back up it's not the same as breaking
your back and crying on Highwire but
still got to get back up I um yeah my
daughter was upset my daughter was upset
last night because I didn't have sushi
in the in the garden when we went and I
said this we're raising a spoiled child
oh she sui angry about the sushi she
wasn't happy about seeing pink she did
no she loved seeing pink and then her
you didn't give her any vodar and sodas
did you no but I did what what happened
is I did cuz I got drunk I did spill a
vakka soda all over and then my
daughter's jacket fell in it so then she
wore that jacket on the train that was
just laced with vodka soda all over her
SLE that's some people don't understand
that's a real New Yorker he understands
even though it's night it's 10:30 it's
Sunday night he knows his daughter's got
to get used to the train because you
took a car would have took you two hours
to get home oh kid me yeah we took the
we took the we took the subway my
daughter's been on the subway uh uh many
times she said um I told you that she
said I said this train you know it's
Subway I said it's for the public CU she
was like why are there so many people on
this train I said for the public this is
the public train she was like do they
have Catholic trains well that was a
good bit that's a good quick I was like
yeah she would Sav that for the ACT well
I got yeah I got nothing in the act the
marathon was yesterday oh yeah the New
York City marathon could you ever see
yourself running it oh my God no I I
mean when I used to smoke cigarettes I
used to go running sometimes like five
miles that was the best I could ever do
five miles I don't think I ever even got
to five miles it's pretty impressive but
it was crazy I know I came in yesterday
from and just the fans the enthusiasm
they're all out there cheering with
these beautiful green black and white
flags and red flags cheering right they
were screaming really intensely
passionate about the whole thing it was
really great about yeah yes yes about
about the Palestinian Marathon oh that's
what it was yes yes I I um the marathon
was from the river to the Sea how they
run I forget the route the route it goes
it starts in my ex-home burrow of St is
I just said from the river to the Sea
that was supposed to be a joke and you
go well it starts in my what do you mean
from the river to the sea oh forget it
if you don't get that joke I don't want
to talk about it damn it well we're
going to get to history because I'm
reading a book that's proven we're lied
to about American history and it's
bothering me we're lied about we lied to
Paul River lie oh come on it's a lie
Thomas Jefferson lie what yes he have
wouldn't te decaration of independ he
didn't sleep with the slaves no well no
that he did oh the negative parts are
true and the in the lies a coincidence
I'll give me a break
um um I uh what did he do if he if he
didn't help with the uh well no that
it's just that they were saying that you
know how we were taught that he wrote
the Declaration of Independence and it
was all kind of his idea and all that
and like he was the the Founding Father
the wise one that R none of it true he's
borrowed it from other people there was
a declaration of independence in in like
the state of Massachusetts that he
borrowed from and then it was like there
was like 10 guys that wrote it but he's
the one that got the credit are you sure
you not about the you not talk about the
con Connecticut Constitution right
remember they had the Connecticut
Constitution before we came up with the
Constitution no Declaration of
Independence is was based on that other
thing you know on the um I think it was
R Magna carter yeah not far from there
but but the Constitution the Connecticut
Constitution they had it beforehand but
that's a well-known thing you know it's
a wellknown well yeah well you're right
they don't get the kind of credit they
should yeah I but it doesn't matter
anyway I we saw about Tesla today and
speaking of Edison what he say what
happened I don't know I just saw
something on social media about him he
shooting the arrow at the new Tesla what
Joe Rogan sh AR the guy Tesla oh Nikolai
Tesla his face yeah right for this fun
fact Nikolai Tesla killed himself or
died in the New Yorker Hotel and we used
to film the MTV show Guy Code and girl
code at the New Yorker Hotel on the
second floor and the cameraman said they
did not like filming there cuz they
believe it was haunted by Tesla's Ghost
and the camera used to shut off in the
middle of filming so it it it disrupted
filming of Guy Code and girl code so
much that MTV had to pay to move Studios
wow that is that is a fun fact that
hotel is creepy it is creepy something
about it you know yeah I mean I feel
like a lot of stuff happen there you
know look at this Midtown Lower
Manhattan foot traffic down
33% unbelievable well a lot of people
are not I'm not walking cuz I have an
Achilles injury oh you do it won't have
you ever had achilles tendonitis I no I
I told my achilles you told your
Achilles yeah how I told you that story
no but tell I was on Adam Sandler's
movies one of his movies and we does
Halloween before that so it was one of
those other ones and we're on the set of
we're on the set play you know he plays
basketball all the time me right and he
goes do you want to play and I go yeah
and I start playing and the I'm being
covered by Joe vessie you know Joe
vessie sh the legend Joe vessie the his
father Peter vessie legendary sport he's
he's a great one player yes great ball
player yes Joe I love Joe and so I shoot
I score and I'm thinking you know what
I'm not that old and the next play I get
the ball I run and I pop and I pop my
achilles but the good ball was it was on
the set it was in the H this house the
house with a mansion with a Godfather
horse's head scene that exact house that
exact house it's the best house in La
it's right above Sunset it's this
beautiful mansion the guy had six black
clad like assassin uh bodyguards in the
house at all times cuz it's such big
property right that you have these woods
and stuff he had six guys that were like
you know and so when it popped was it
just excruciating pain right there no it
was it hurt but it was more scary than
painful what did you do then how did you
rehab it have to go surgery I didn't
rehab it the way I was supposed to I had
surgery and then they say you got to go
to rehab and I went for a few weeks but
then I just stopped and they go don't
stop they go everybody stops and they
never get completely better I go I won't
stop I stopped and is it completely
better no still I know this a kill it
it's so it's so um every time I walk
it's like this intense intense pain but
what can you do there's nothing you can
do sometimes Colin
you if you're saying what can you do
then we none of us have any hope oh cuz
I used to be a physical therapist yes I
forgot everything though he goes ah what
can you do what you what is it 1930 I
know I like you're like somebody's Uncle
like yeah what can you do it's like no
you would physic
you should there are are things you can
do I forgot everything I forgot I went
through three and a half years of a
doctorate level program I swear to God I
don't know how to do anything I would if
you were like oh I hurt my ACL I would
probably do whatever the rehab is
opposite way yeah but meanwhile here you
are complaining because you have a
little ACL problem you're popping down
you're listening here comes and it comes
pink she broke her back and she actually
did enough work to come back there's a
picture of right there I think no that's
zuberg well either way look at him he
was trying to fight toward ACL while
sparring Lis Gomez but that's the
problem you know when you're a nerd you
really shouldn't be trying to get ready
for a real fight yeah you really
shouldn't and I think you know I I think
like you know these acl's everybody's
starting to tear their ACLS now
everyone's starting to get more injured
I think uh I saw something that because
of the types of food we're eating and
because of the types of like CrossFit
and things like that we're doing you
think we're getting strong but we're
actually PR making ourselves prone to
more injury well maybe uh Trump was
right there Trump maybe Trump was right
in that he's a uh remember he's like I
never worked out I he eat only only
vegetables yeah like Sam Roberts from
Jim and Sam now here's the
question yes he looks like a vegetable
Sam Roberts he looks like a squash um
so he does so so here's the question
though with potential World War III
coming potential that the things are
bubbling the United States government
has hinted at potentially bringing back
a draft now my question to you is with
the draft will then gender matter well
then people start saying well you know
what I actually am a woman and I'm not
I'm not get I can't get drafted what
what will people say about gender then
well but I mean it's not that people are
saying they're not a they're saying I am
actually am a woman now but I'm saying
will they go back to will they will they
what do we got US Congress moves closer
to making women register for the draft
yeah oh women register yeah because then
what happens though but what if you're
but my question is with the draft you
have men you have women but then what
happens if you're non-binary do you get
drafted how do you get around these
rules now that's the issue yeah where
where are you where are you in the
barracks really is the question that's
what it yeah but if it comes down to a w
like that everybody's going you know I
mean would you go I'm too old no but
what if they said you know what we need
everybody I would love it you would do
it yeah something to do how about today
how about today I'm to Florida I'm get I
get off the train I get off the train uh
Long Island Railroad and I see there's a
homeless woman and she's she's you
know people walking past her and she
goes could somebody buy me a water all I
want is a water and everyone's walking
past her so I stopped I was like all
right I'll get her a water so I get two
Poland Springs and she goes I wanted a
pelino I swear to God that's gold and so
I made I I gave it back and then the
lady gave me a pelino and I had to pay
like a 85 Cent difference first of all
she didn't even say thank you to it's a
greatest it's the greatest New York
story of all time it's true but at the
same time it also reminds me yet some
Anonymous person yet when he goes to O
and Stein around the corner he doesn't
get me a
tea they do have good danishes that
reminds me of the old joke by the way
tell me so the the guy selling pencils
the blind guy they Ed that blind guy
sell pencil on the you know in front of
the stores and there's a businessman
every day he gives a guy 25 cents and
doesn't take a pencil for 30 years he
just gives the guy 25 cents never takes
a pencil
and then one day the guy goes to him
excuse me sir he goes I know what you're
going to ask me why do I every day give
you 25 cents I never take a pencil he
goes no I just wanted to tell you the
price of pencils went up to 50
cents it's like that lady there it is
smart I like it I like a good Street
joke yeah why not why the hell not it
doesn't matter what are you doing today
what you got act like it's in my act you
go it doesn't matter I'm just selling it
P casually act like I committed some FAA
on this goddamn show okay sorry I'm not
talking about latte versus pumpkin spice
like those other two hacks J Rosa and S
volan okay oh my God if you Joe heard
you say that he'd be so upset he like
everybody's got everybody only talks
about me for the material it was Furious
he came in I was talking to Ian F Dan on
the show the other day and we were
talking about something with Joe and
then Joe barges into the show he goes
would you even have an act if it wasn't
for making fun of me good point I was
like shut up go back to your house in
Pennsylvania it's stiff but Joe's got
the house he's got his own side
businesses he's doing good we might
start doing the podcast man you do from
the S I would do it from the sandwich
shop I would do it from the sandwich
shop too I would like that a little more
energy and excitement why not and then
as as to steal my idea I'm going to tell
Joe I'm gon to say Joe me and you should
do a podcast he's going to say no the
boy what I guarantee he's going to say
no man we baked the bread there it's not
good for the roast
beef I could talk Joe into doing it for
the sandwich sh can I'm going to say Joe
I've never done a podcast I hate
podcasts I'm going to do one with you
only if we do it from your sandwich up
we have sandwiches I went to Colin
Quinn's apartment for the first time two
weeks so lovely lovely space yeah lovely
space podcast there big what we have the
room you have room you know we could do
there actually what my apartment a b you
could put a bowling alley there because
it's about the length of a a it is that
bowling part it is I felt as soon as I
walked in I I wanted to roll something
down right down that alley it's got that
thing well when I had the 20 kiles I had
the bike and I was just roll down and
when you asked your wife to if you could
put in a bowling alley what was her
answer I've asked her for all those
kinds of things she's just like she just
looked at me like her mouth turns down
in disgust even though she knows I'm
joking she knows I'm half joking and she
just has that slight disgust yeah your
wife likes me though your wife I'm
accept your wife does like that's good
hey that's what you want you want you
want to be AC be the guy who's accepted
you don't want to be the guy who
people's lives like I don't like you
hang out with that guy you want to be
the guy like you know but I feel like my
wife like a lot of women do like you but
they know you know what I mean they can
sense they they know who's up to
something they know that they know you
we're all un trust you know what I mean
they they can sense who's a goddamn you
know well I got my new thing I don't
think they like any me likes you that
much they all know you how probably
right well here's my new thing what I've
been doing is is it you know me I love
to travel VOR is the only app that I use
when I'm going to a new city or a new
country I love to go on walking tours on
history tours I love to do all that
stuff VI tour is the only app that I use
it is I I found so many tours that I'm
like this is the best tour I've ever had
in my life and I only go to VOR it could
be funny touching silly transformative
anything you want I mean literally any
type of you know tour experience you're
looking for that's all all you need VI
tour's travel experiences have millions
of real travel reviews so you have the
information you need to book the best
activities for your trip over 300,000
bookable experience in 190 countries
there is something for everyone they
offer everything from simple tours to
Extreme Adventures all you got to do is
download the vior app right now and use
the code vator 10 that's v a t o r10 for
10% off your first booking in the app
one app 300,000 travel experiences
you'll remember do more with VOR listen
I don't want you to have to worry about
buying tickets to your next big event
that's why I'm telling you use game time
it's the fast an easy way to buy tickets
for all the sports music comedy and
Theater events near you they have killer
last minute deals all in prices view
from your seat and the best price
guarantee game time takes the guest work
out of buying tickets I love that you
see the view before your seat before I
love that you see the view of your seat
before you buy you know exactly what to
expect when you arrive there are no
surprises unless Joe D Ro is sitting in
front of you and the game time guarantee
I love that this is the best part you
always get the best price here's what
they do if you find the tickets in the
same section and roll four less game
time will credit you
110% of the difference it is the best
you buy tickets in seconds with two Taps
all the prices show in total right up
front it's a beautiful thing so go ahead
right now and download the game time app
create an account and use the code hey
babe for $20 off your first purchase
terms apply again create an account and
redeem the code H YB a B for
$20 off download game time today last
minute tickets lowest price guaranteed
tomorrow I am in the daa Beach Improv
it's going to be great down in Fort
laale Florida tomorrow Friday and then
shows on Saturday and then the following
week we are in New Haven Connecticut
Thursday Providence Rhode Island Friday
Medford Massachusetts Saturday all those
shows are almost sold out then we have
Phoenix Arizona December uh 2 uh
December 1st and 2nd at Friday Saturday
Phoenix Arizona um back at the um
standup live which is a great venue um
I've been there a couple of times before
but I'm doing my brand new hour going to
do a bunch of got some crowd work got
some new bits you haven't heard so go
check it out and then Salt Lake City and
Denver all those shows are almost sold
out and then we added The Wil turn
theater in Los Angeles and a show in San
Diego in Jan chrisd comedy.com for
tickets I'm really proud of this hour so
come have fun and love your life is is
it well here's my new
thing it's great okay well I accept that
here's my new thing now listen so what
I've been doing to stay safe you took
your glass off and I put mine on oh that
means I'm going put mine on then go
ahead we'll never this the promise of
this episode is one of us will always
have our glasses on that's a promise we
can make to our viewers um so so the new
thing I've been doing to stay safe is I
go on the road right and this takes away
the Temptation is I'll see a girl or
maybe sometimes multiple women and I'll
take pictures of them in my head and
I'll just snapshot them in my head and
then I go back to the hotel room and
then I get completely butt naked and I
pull a a chair up in front of a mirror
Lube myself up Lube up everything and
then I have a nice masturbation session
with just me and the multiple woman in
my head and then I wake up the next
morning and nobody gets hurt I got
interesting I'm not I'm not cheating I'm
not affecting them they're in my brain
and they're they're locked in there
forever but nothing you could do about
that and then I have a nice I have a
nice moment with myself it feels good I
I thought it
was I thought it was going to be like I
I look at them I lock in my head and I
go oh if I'm a her for four years she's
going to be busting my balls about this
with this one for 3 years she's going to
wake up and just be like she had a bad
breath that day and she's going to be
cursing me out about something I thought
it was that I do say though I am at the
age now I guess you know you and I
spoken about this before I do look at
like you know when you're like oh you
know that woman right there and then you
just think about how exhausting it would
be to try to start over that that's
that's my main motivation right now for
good just staying with one the same one
I'm like it's too exhausting to do
anything I'm exhausting I think that uh
really or that whole story Not only was
it here you just let me say if I got
this correctly you Lube yourself up
naked in a chair but you're in front of
a mirror yes it makes so you're not
looking at those girls you're watching
yourself whack off right where are the
girls and it sounds like just a
narcissist who's jerking off to his own
image in the mirror well because the
left side of my chest looks like a
woman's tit so I like to see it I mean
there's no woman there's no visual just
hey sometimes guys get in there too I
like it that you're old school though
you actually can just conjure up the
real woman that's how we used to jerk
off back in the old days cuz there was
no porn there was no porn no you you you
I'm barely I'm barely uh I'm barely on
porn anymore I just yeah porn is crazy
it's ridiculous it's too much it's it's
it's it's uh yeah porn is is is has lost
the I remember in my early 20s in my
apartment and the girl I was seeing she
comes over and I I put a I had a point
tape it and she goes what's that I go
porn and she goes what and I put it on
and she goes what the hell is wrong with
you go what she goes you watch this I go
yeah porn like I thought it was so
normal
natural I was like Travis ble when he
brings you to the porn theater yeah in
Taxi Driver well there used to be one
porn VHS tape it was called the the the
Spanish porn we had it amongst our
friends it was a blue VHS cassette tape
yeah VHS right VHS and everybody would
pass that around and then I got I'm I
think I've told the story before I'm the
one that got caught with that my mother
caught me with the tape and she smashed
it up into a million pieces and I woke
up the next morning and there was a post
said get this filth out of my house and
then I had to tell our friend Frankie
that I'm the idiot who lost the point
and they still bring that up to this
day Spanish porn well it's like my
mother when I was dealing I was dealing
weed and my mother found the weed in my
house and you know she she had heard of
weed it was the 70s but she goes you're
a [__] drug dealer you're a drug
dealer I go it's weed it's a different
story and she goes well don't worry
about it I flush it down the tril I go
you're going to get me kills yeah Sergio
shakon is Gonna Come and beat you
up Sergio shakon in hot water go check
out the uh the series what is the series
called block by block block by block I
was telling pimp one of my favorite
series and I proposed an idea of what
about block by block through Ridgewood
Queen yeah we do you in in Metropolitan
Avenue or something Metropolitan well
Myrtle Avenue Metropolitan Avenue is the
other gang but we're the Myrtle boys uh
we will do it Myrtle yeah block by block
old school German architecture called St
Mias Church
this episode uh with Sergio the uh lower
e side was um great was awesome I love
it block by block going around and I
like the one you guys did on the upper
west side with the guy or was the Upper
East Side it was one of the first ones
yeah there was that it was Hell's
Kitchen in Upper East Side that guy that
guy from the neighborhood was awesome oh
yeah I love I watched this too when you
were talking about uh uh your comedy
special that everyone knows all the
comedians know the Pittsburgh Pirates
jacket jacket which was good and now I
found out we're watching that you pretty
much improv most of that and you weren't
on the you hadn't done any sets at all
for months before that that was the
first time on stage yeah I I was so
that's why I had to kind of jump down in
the crowd and play around and do crowd
work you were you were blanket on
material I was crowd work but I knew I
was before I get up there why like I
wasn't blanking I knew I was like I'm
screwed this this half hour why but what
but you had no choice you had to do it
what's that you had no choice you had to
do it I had to do it especially in those
days you had no choice which is
interesting because you're the guy now
in standup who like you're at the Club
every night like you're the comedy
connoisseur but here then you were like
ah yeah connoisseur is the wrong word
but um I was doing a lot of crowd work I
just want to do a c with a
[Laughter]
c man I cooked yesterday how about that
your are ringings french onion pasta you
did yep and I've been making different
types of salmon dishes French onion
pasta ready for this that sounds bad
what do you think of this ready for this
here's what I did cut up spin cheese
spinach like you know fresh spinach
Tomatoes put the salmon in the middle
then I put onion and chive cream cheese
on the salmon hold on cream cheese ruin
it onions no onions and peppers then I
put it in the oven preheat the oven 350°
put the salmon in for about 20 minutes
simultaneously I got water boiling I
poured in tricolor rotini pasta okay
then the salmon cooked I took the rotini
pasta out I mixed it all together and I
made like a s lemon onion cream cheese
pasta with spinach and tomatoes and the
kids loved it yeah the kids Lov it me
you went to the show in empty stomach
cuz you didn't want to eat it no I did
eat it I ate all EMP
stomach and then I made a pumpkin pie
dip wow vanilla instant pudding mix
pumpkin pie spice um maple
syrup pumpkin
puree and chocolate chips that sounds
weird but I guess it's good it was good
you such a cook I I like all that cream
in your food it sounds like you're into
Northern nataliia cooking I don't go for
that [__] what do you like I like like
old school red sauce Italian food and
Spanish seafood I like seafood with
pasta with any kind of a red sauce or
garlic and oil or anything like that
here's the predicament I'm in what
Jasmine my girl makes amazing sauce but
her ex-boyfriend taught her how to do it
how do you deal with that what do you
mean why does that bother you I guess it
should is your ex-boyfriend Italian I
think so you don't even know yeah sounds
like it's really not a predicament your
in yeah I was just trying to make
conversation for the show oh sorry well
um I was just trying to raise the stakes
raise the steak but everybody knows
you're not the jealous type we're not
jealous type I'm really not well to the
point where I think it's I don't care
I'm not jealous um of any uh I I just
don't well with relationships I just
don't care if somebody cheated on me I
would be like great yeah I was always
like that you were like that let me but
let's talk about something more
important which is my new hour so here's
my big plan I'll just tell you the
beginning of it okay the big plan which
is to shave my beard because the white
in my beard is really I I look like
death I look like and you say thing is
Tom what you saying no I think he look
great thanks but what about on camera
can I call it you know one thing I like
about the Taliban probably the only
thing was the Taliban used to the old
guys would color they be red purple they
used berries they didn't even have to
spend money on it what if I couple my
beard like Taliban type colors I like
that I don't tell people it's Taliban I
like that I think wait what don't you
like about the white beard I feel like
it looks good you look like uh mature I
trust you you're a leader wait a minute
what did Tom Papa say about it oh Tom
Papa said listen Tom we were having a
big one of those the comedy seller we
have these comedy seller dinners once
every couple of years yeah I got invited
to one and they never got invited back
invited to one and they people out like
The Audition one person each dinner
Chris came I didn't think he did that
badly okay Colin vouch for me I was
Colin's pick and I thought I thought he
did well what what lost his vote um he
wasn't like he would start with his
Chrissy energy but then halfway through
he would kind of lose it he lose
confidence and Wilt he Wilt it because
because they call him yeah because the
thing is his nickname is Wilt Chamberlin
Wilt yes Wilt the stilt Wilt the stilt
that because the thing was is it was it
was Colin you know Bobby Kelly Keith
Robinson Jim Norton right SD from the
comedy cell so they all hit each other
with like good jokes making fun of each
other me as a new guy can't come in and
then start making fun of them it's
disrespectful so you kind of have to
just listen but the the the the Catch 22
with that dinner is you got to come out
and start killing but it's it's if you
do it and you and you you're going to
piss somebody off and disrespect a
comedy Elder so I just figured I'm just
going to sit here and stay nothing and
slowly just wean myself out and then I
said well enjoy this one dinner and then
I'll never get invited back he's 100%
right yeah I can't deny it he's 100%
right but um but anyway Tom Papa who's
really organized at the dinner every
time even though no one pays Tom's like
is everybody down for dinner this week
and we're like okay fine so this time he
came and Tom Tom was on fire and he just
nailing people he was you know Tom's got
an edge to him he does and he goes and
Colin why don't you shave you don't have
to let everybody know you gave
up and then I was like wow that looked
like I it was a good one I had to laugh
but also I was like does it look like
you gave up does it look like you if you
don't shave I'm like uh what's her name
Carrie Brad if you don't shave does it
look like you gave
up
um
yeah I mean I don't know I think I think
it looks I think it looks
good you to you're the one who told me
you texted me two weeks ago maybe this
was after dinner now it's starting to
make sense you texted me out of nowhere
I said what are you doing today you said
preparing for the final chapter of my
career well the final chapter is yeah I
want to do a spe I want to do a well
we'll talk about this I don't want to
talk about on the air but I want to do a
big special to end it all I got it I got
the name for it special
wesel
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right um well I um I like the beard
I think the Beard's fun I think the
Beard's in Pimp's got a nice beard
Pimp's got a big yeah it's it's not
white if it was white it would be wild
Pimp's beard would Mike Cannon has gray
hair he's young gray is different yours
I would call that gray yeah but on
camera this looks white right down about
the bottom line is this what is your
wife think that's the only thing that
matters for the first time I asked her
last night about it and she goes like
this she goes well I mean it is pretty
white I was like Wow Wow and then didn't
say and then just continued on yeah she
didn't want to say it she did not say it
it's like if it's right up there with
like I'd have to see you without it then
you're like oh that person hates you you
wearing somebody goes I'd have to see
you without that you're like Jesus Jesus
I'm going to do it it so you're going to
shave the beard no I don't know what
about what about going the other way and
just growing it as long as you can how
oh I hate that David let himon look that
looks psychotic you think so well now
you're not get pass I could have put
into it now you're not going to get on
his Netflix show you would had the
opportunity to interview zalinski and
you screwed it up what do you mean
zinski Letterman interviewed zalinski
from he did I can't believe zilinski is
still alive why they everyone thought he
was going to be dead two years ago the
guy's living I know meanwhile Putin you
know
is in trouble Vladimir he's sick he gets
better what happened I'm what that um
well speaking of Putin us Pentagon
announced nuclear bomb 24 times more
powerful than the one dropped in Japan
what's the difference how it doesn't
need to be it's going to eviscerate us
and when was this today today that we
have it we got it 24 why saying he's
going to invate us hopefully we won't
aim at ourselves right but I would think
the nuclear fallout as I've learned on
the show trov on HBO is is um it'll be
over here yeah just like the dinosaurs
it won't hit us it could we're we're
lucky where we live it's true when those
smoke when that smoke came from Canada I
go what the hell even Canada's attacking
us well we got the oceans man we
geographically we are geographically in
great sh brand new sweatsh from Lou
Lemon I spilled coffee on it damn that's
the problem wait a minut now what we got
to come up with an invention that's on
your phone that can take all those
little pesky stains out wow like an app
that that'll like it off yes H it's like
a barcode laser right on your phone and
if bar if we're speaking of bars of soap
we only go with Dr Squatch Dr Squatch or
Dr Sasquatch is it Dr Squatch Dr
Sasquatch Dr Squatch soap it's awesome
go use the promo code hey babe do Dr
Squatch I think it's Dr Squatch or Dr
Sasquatch soap but it's amazing name um
Dr Squatch uh great soap
um what else what what I texted you pimp
what I want to there was something
something else an article or something I
want to bring up to Colin they're all
here okay the the we said oh the the
Shipwreck the colum how about this the
Holy Grail of shipwrecks $20 billion of
sunken treasure they say Colin there's
more money lost in the Ocean than we
have in circulation right now 20 billion
is not that much in circul no but that's
just one little part of the ocean
they're going to find they're going down
to some ship shipwreck and the problem
is the the governments have said if you
can go down and get the the treasure
it's yours and they said there's
billions of dollars down there so
Colombia's president right now they're
going down to get this uh 20 billion
dollars sunken treasure and the question
is who does it go to the government the
people the cartels that's why I that's
who it should go to well it probably go
to whoever goes down there we you go
down there and get that money we need
some good were you a swimmer in high
school um no I was run into some people
that go yeah I was a swimmer and I'm
like it's so weird to be a swimmer in
high school but some people were
yeah strange well I went to a we didn't
even have a pool in my SCH no me neither
no New York we don't have activities
like that no you don't have swimming and
stuff like that too much right New York
no because what am I going to do go swim
in the you're not going to go in the
ocean water what am I going to go all
the way out to mon talk to swim well you
go to Rockway back in those days yeah
but not well Manhattan Beach we used to
go to Coney Island all the time we
didn't really swim that much I went to
Jones Beach uh I would mostly go to
Jones Beach or yeah Rockway Rock I go to
Brighton and Cony Island right there hey
we The Beach Boys yeah look at that
that's a good name for our podcast me
and Joe's new sandwich podcast yes the
Beach Boys um Ryan Air you ever flown it
Ryan a no I never heard of it that's the
one in in England I mean in the UK or
Europe they fly sard they fly all over
Europe cheap flights Sardine Can seating
on planes will soon be the norm look at
them look they got all these levels of
of seats just kind of that looks like
those C130 youever go in the military
flights where they just strap you all in
together yeah yeah well this is ai's
prediction of how air travel will evolve
in the next well they have they have air
makes predictions think about that AI is
also in charge of rent now really yeah
all the landlords tap into AI That's why
the prices are going up wow AI is in
charge of podcast ads AI will go through
a podcast ad and if you don't hit it the
way that they've programmed it you will
lose money on the the you'll get
demonetized it's a whole problem AI I am
a fan of Dr Squatch it's best soap
around see use their voice and be like
hey this guy's in the they like it he's
one of us yeah they AI they look they
generated nude images of girls out of
New Jersey high school and triggered
police probe but it wasn't real well um
why is it a picture the why is it say
nude girls and it's a picture of the
Pope dress in one of those Jack you know
he's got kimp likes to throw that in
there once in a while as a deep fake
that is a deep fake AI is making images
of the Pope do weird stuff right he's in
he's in one of those jackets the so they
just yeah they're just trying to show
that AI you can feed anybody into it and
make them naked or make them whatever
they want yeah I know you it's it's one
of those things where I when I first
start before comedy all I wanted to do
was be able to have some kind of job or
career that couldn't be taken over by
robots back then there wasn't even AI
wasn't that's why became a physical
therapist cuz I was like oh I can do
this like they'll always need people but
now ai absolutely is going to take over
physical therapy there probably you
could be able to put your kiles in a
machine and it'll do everything the
therapists could do and it's going to
take over it's already taken over comedy
AI gener crowd work clips and all that
it's like a mass massage chair massage
chair that does what physical therapist
used to do it can but wait a minute what
are you saying comedy how's it going to
take over comedy and crowd work well I'm
saying a already you can do AI you can
do people do AI crowd work clips and you
could do you could AI generate anything
yeah whatever you want to do you could
type it in we're going to do the new
special AI crowd but here's what I to
say these girls it's not really the
girls naked it's fake yeah but the
police still had to investigate because
it was underage girl right but the
police it looks so real that the right
that that's what we're saying pimp right
like it'll fool the police their face
and applying it to like I could put you
in the scene of a crime and it looks
real enough that the police will be like
you have to prove now I guarantee you
somebody's going to somebody's going to
get wrongfully convicted that cuz they
just happened to be in the same place
but well I hate to say it but but I was
ahead of my time when I was seven my
dream was to be invisible and then
go into women's houses and watch them
try on
bras there it is folks very Animal House
there's the clip um there's the clip no
context I didn't want to think about no
context
Colin well between the two of you you're
jerking off in a mirror he's that was
really combine those with theyi at least
that was seven during
mine yeah that was a little bit yeah
that I did that in Columbus last week
but it's so funny because I when I would
visualize it when I was seven I didn't
imagine women's tits all I imagine was
them in the bra like this right crazy
that's all you wanted well that's when I
was a kid the only thing I used to uh I
used to watch over on repeat Jam Lee
Curtis dancing around for Hest
swartzenegger and True Lies that's all I
needed was just the slightest tip of the
top hint to the top of her nipple that's
what me we would talk about in school I
remember going back I went to same I
remember talking to all the boys in the
back of class like did you see the top
of jam Lee Curtis's nipple I got the VHS
my mom would be like where you really
love True Lies I'm like oh yeah I love
you know find that VHS throw it out too
I know I'm a Schwarzenegger fan just
smash that one too yeah Smash It Up um
Eagles fans get this is the most Eagles
Philadelphia Eagles thing to do Eagles
fans get married in parking lot tailgate
before Cowboys game that's nice that's
great that's nice I was at your there
they go there it is that's beautiful
look at that it's beautiful thing pink
yesterday has some balls on stage at
Madison Square Garden she goes by the
way the Eagles won today people Li oh my
God oh what's her problem because she's
pink she could do anything I know she's
went she's Philadelphia she went to uh
she's from like one of those towns like
you know doown or one of these towns by
the King of Prussia moall right she's an
a you garbage fan
think she probably is
um oh so see here now that I'm actually
I do agree with Tom Papa now that I'm
seeing the banner of your YouTube you do
look better clean
shaven God damn it I mean I'm just
looking at it it looks nice why can't
you just leave a mustache on like Andrew
Schultz dude you if you came out with
Schultz's mustache and haircut that
would be that would break the internet I
think that would be I am curious so when
did Tom Papa say that how long has this
been in your head um no but it didn't it
didn't it was in my head a little bit
before that to be honest but when he
said that and it was like everybody
laughed in a way where they're like
nobody was like that's crazy people were
like
ha that was probably two month maybe two
months ago oh it's been festering oh
it's been wow I man I really I haven't
got invited to that dinner in six
years now that's been festering has
anyone let me ask you a question since
I've been eliminated has anyone else
been tried out have you tried out Jared
freed have you tried out some of the
other guys you know what's funny I don't
think Jared Freed's have been tried out
but I feel like he would probably be
good at it but you know you know they
had Ryan Hamilton once you know it
didn't go well I thought Ryan would kill
because every loves Ryan but he's a
little too nice yes and you have to be
two things you have to be you have to be
mean but you also have to be loud it's a
loud room yes so even if you're funny if
you were like a Todd Barry no people go
what right right so Todd doesn't get
invited too too too low tone you'd have
to be uh yeah that's what I thought
you'd I honestly if I had to bet if I
was a betting man I would have bet on
you I think that I think that because
because the I'm all about respect with
the older guys it's hard for me even now
I've known you guys a long time it's
still hard for me to make fun like me
and Mike Canon will make fun of each
other cuz we're you know the same AG but
the older guys I'm like ah I can't first
of all anytime I you know Bobby Kelly
yells at me once a month so I know I
can't make fun of him or even attempt to
but so I I got that and then you know
Keith I can't say anything too Jim and
Jim you know and I laugh together but
I'm not going to you know like like
remember when we were at that dinner B
the waiter came over and asked Jim what
he wanted and then um Bobby said he
wants um snail shells just give him
shells and it was funny and I was like
it was just a funny thing to say yeah
yeah but by the way the special guest
this time usually it's a comedian it was
we were downtown we went to Noble
downtown which really annoyed me I don't
like that kind of I don't like that kind
of food and then the special guest was
the waiter from the other place
really yeah wow a surprise guest I love
it I don't yeah I'm not a I'm not a I'm
not a no boo guy for me if I'm going to
go out to dinner I want to just I
typically only want to go out to an
Italian restaurant yeah I want to eat
sushi and things like that by myself I
don't want to go to dinner with that
right I don't know why I have nothing
against a Japanese no but but even
though we have a I think I speak for the
whole room when I say your dish you
cooked last night sounded disgusting it
sounded like you took delicious pasta
and ruined it with cream cheese
I'm telling you if if you bake it though
onion chive cream cheese specifically
it's even worse and how about this then
I took King Hawaiian slider rolls and I
made a bacon egg and cheese with uh a
Chipotle mayo for the kids oh that was
not they ate that they're starting to
eat my I'm start here's the problem
though you ready for this I'm starting
to cook more now and jazz is starting to
get mad at me cuz she's like what do you
taking my ey cook I was like I thought
it'd be helpful in the kitchen and she's
like why don't you just just keep doing
your [__] comedy and sit there and
I'll feed you so you got to be careful
you got to be careful she doesn't say
[__] comedy does she no no no she's
supportive of it now all
right now she's a of it now she's she's
coming around she's coming around right
now she coming around she's yeah she's
coming around to it I mean you know
comedy's not for
everybody my
comedy who's your favorite comedian
Gabriel glaus who is our favorite
comedian um who does she laugh at the
most I'm trying to think who she lik
well she liked her and her mom I told
you love your New York story especially
when you do the Puerto Rican bits um
they like those but I wonder who her who
is her actual favorite yeah she probably
doesn't tell you no who did she want to
she likes Sebastian a lot she likes him
she likes Taylor Tomlinson she's Taylor
Tomlin hosting a hot new show yes yes
sir CBS Late Night congrats to her
DT ton yeah
that's it I like tayor Tanson yeah I
like um I like uh yeah I don't know I I
I texted her congrats on the show and
she wrote back thanks what what more can
you hope for yeah that's it I guess look
at this sweet fishes Cafe in Thailand
where the floor is filled with water and
fish swim amongst the customers what do
you think of that I actually like that
idea what do you mean wait a minute wait
it's you're you're saying like your feet
are wet Oh I thought it was glass that's
stupid anyone could do that you got to
be restaurant got to be there with the
fish what if somebody throws in a couple
of um
piranha oh yeah piranha then sudden
eating your toes yeah o I don't want
that I I um that's why should shoot my
new comedy
special where do you want to shoot your
new comedy special where do you want to
shoot at I don't know maybe Long Island
somewhere oo the Paramount oh I like the
Paramount hey tonight Monday Night
Football who do you got the Jets or the
Chargers the Jets of course you think
the Jets what's going to be the score
cuz this comes out Thursday so I want to
I don't how the charges are this year
are they good charges are three and four
I believe jets are four and three jet
type team um I would say um I would say
the Jets are going to
win my first thought was 17 to3 but now
I'm saying I don't want it to be such a
boring game 3117 Jets 317 Jets this is
on this is hours before the Monday night
football game this episode comes out in
three days so we're going to see we're
going to put your uh prediction to the
test it is sad did you watch the Jets
and Giants this is the whole problem if
it was any other City you'd be like well
you know it's a small town they don't
have the kind of money we have the
biggest Market in the world and our
teams are so mediocre my whole life I
was 10 years old when Joe namoth led the
Jets Super Bowl same year the Mets won
the World Series the Knicks won the NBA
and I was like this is probably how it's
going to be most of my life Champions is
New York and ever since then they all
suck Met's had a couple of good using it
that's about it hello fresh baby Olaf
fresa America's number one meal kit the
holidays are right around the corner and
hello fresh can help take the stress out
of dinner by delivering everything you
need to cook up tasty meals right to
your door saving you tons of time the
holiday season can be hectic and that's
where helloof Fresh's 15minute meals
come in these quick fixes help you get a
wholesome meal on the table and less
time than it takes to get delivery just
like always hellofresh as ingredients
travel from the farm to your door so you
know they are fresh and everything
arrives pre-portioned so you can get
right to cooking quick hellofresh we use
it with my family we that's how we Bond
we sit around we cook we love it right
now all you have to do is go to
hellofresh.com heyab free and use the
code heyab free for free breakfast for
Life One breakfast item per box while
subscription is active that's free
breakfast forlife at hellofresh.com
heyab free with code hey bab free I mean
free breakfast for Life how can you go
wrong go to the website put in the promo
code hellofresh America's number one
meal kit let me tell you about the
absolute best toothbrush I've ever had
in my life quip baby look at this hit
that
button and we're brushing folks quip
toothbrush I use it every day it's great
to travel because it has like this like
plastic case that goes over it that's
awesome keeps my uh toothbrush germ free
I love the vibration the little Sonic
vibration on my teeth it's amazing
you're going to want to use it on other
parts of your body but do not do that
this is only a toothbrush for your teeth
and it is awesome let me tell you about
quip good health starts with good habits
and quip makes it Easy by delivering all
the Oral Care Essentials you need to
care fore mouth they also have these
amazing mints this tooth floss seriously
quip is and I love the toothpaste it's
so minty fresh and I just feel like my
teeth are cleaner wouldn't you say my
teeth are looking
better quip baby quip is doing from now
on my friend are going to start calling
me Colin quip I love quip so much it is
lightweight and Sleek design no wires no
bulky charges to weigh you down
multi-use Travel cover that doubles as a
mirror amount for Less clutter and it is
it really does it looks awesome skip the
batteries and snap into healthy habits
with the new rechargeable electric
toothbrush all the features of the
original quip plus one magnetic charge
Powers up to three months of brushing I
never have to I'm I'm telling you I
barely charge this thing I really do
like stand by this product this is the
best toothbrush I've ever
had the water flosser it hits all the
right spots with gentle or deep clean
pressure at the touch of a button extra
wide lid that fits right under the
faucet and fills up in seconds $7
replacement floss uh uh floss tip
shipped to you every three months to
keep things flowing smoothly and prevent
mineral deposits from building up every
time you pop our new mints you'll be
caring for your mouth inside and out
Boldman flavors keep your breath
confidently fresh and you'll get a boost
of vitamin D here look I'll show you
I'll show you the mints right here look
these are the mints right here look at
these unbelievable these quip mints and
they're just look they pop right open
like a Pez dispenser it's fun and the
mints are so fresh I love them and you
guys are going to get a great discount
all you do is you got to go to
getquip.com heyab right now and you will
get 20% off any electric toothbrush mint
and gum dispenser or water flosser
that's get quip
/ab right now that's 20% off any
electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser or water flaer at
getquip.com heab that is
gqi
p.com quip the good habits company what
you're noticing is you're exhausted
because of your child you're not mad at
each other and you're not mad at the
child you're mad because you're not
sleeping so sounds like the new hour
there it is so I said what you have to
do now you know what bugs me before we
continue yes every time I say something
but it bugs me in general it's my own
ego when I go that's a great idea for a
joke that's a great you like yeah and
you just dismiss it immediately it
infuriates me go on well because I the
only jokes I get are from ai ai
generated material um no it is I I I I
was thinking about doing a oneman show
you have any advice oh lay off you want
not um I uh I no I think uh I've I've me
and JZ were talk talking about that the
other day where we're like oh yeah we
just cuz a couple of our friends now are
starting to get divorced starting to
happen you know we're 39 40 so divorce
happens and what's the common thing they
all have in common what's the
commonality they started together they
got together when they were in their
late 20s they were married and now they
have little kids and now divorced and
we're like now see we we did that we now
now we could you can we could just go we
almost like hardened against each other
where we're like yeah I just know I know
how to we know how to pick up each
other's slack now you know when when now
I know now I know exactly now I know
when she's like when it's like a rough
morning with the kids I know now go
change the baby go help get the school
uniform out where I I never used to know
that I used to be like that's her job
she's the woman I do the comedy but now
I realize it's a great you you just got
through telling her she told you you do
your comedy and I'll do the womanly
things I cook no I know yourself
completely um but this will be a great
show and you know another thing I
noticed it doesn't be a show just stand
up for your act how could this not be
this is so interesting and insightful
you don't like my comments on Ukraine
what comments on
my in my new
hour yeah I what you say Ukraine's out
of out of the loop now I know they are
move over Ukraine Here Comes Palestine
yeah
um well Treasure Island are you excited
about that oh it happened oh no it's
happened this Friday I'm excited cuz
tomorrow the shows this episode comes
out Thursday right Pimp's going to be
there at Treasure Island well Pimp's not
going to be at Treasure Island he's at
the other place and so's
are Tina and Tina and Amy and also
there's another big comedian is gonna be
there too
Bari doing the arena I don't know I
think he's doing the win I'm not sure I
love the win you know you been doing the
win I did the win two years ago and then
most recently I did the uh uh
Cosmopolitan and did not if you piss off
Bazi you should text me go hey man if
you want any advice on the win call
[Laughter]
so look oh you got a nice little run
here Key West Theater you got uh Fort
Lauderdale oo see a Florida weekend like
that Thursday December 7th in Key West
and then Saturday December 9th in Fort
Lauderdale that's something you bring
your wife to that's a nice Florida
weekend um yeah if she was to Dr well
she works you know that's right but I
mean um never been to Key West no me
neither you never been to Key West my
life wow are you excited about going no
I'm going after Jimmy Buffett died it's
going to be a time morning period for
them did Jimmy Buffett die yeah he did a
few weeks ago a couple months ago rip
yeah Margaritaville he died don't before
the show aired he'll still be dead okay
true um I do have a question as you uh
have been on the road for so long is
does it get easier or do you always is
it always a chore it's always when you
think about going and when you wake up
to fly you're like what am I doing I'm
going to the same play the same hotel
but then when you get there you're like
and you go on stage it's like this is
kind of fun it's all about the hotel
that's all that matters the flights
don't mean anything it's the hotel do
you have a nice hotel like that last
Hotel Stewart Florida was that I wish I
could have stay there for three days
what was the hotel it was just it was
called the Hutchinson spying in or
something in Jensen Beach and I walk in
I go oh my God it smelled great the room
the oceans right there crashing H
everything about was just you know I
mean the lobby had a good snack area you
know that's important do you when you
are on the road do you leave the H are
you guys like to walk around in the
morning and be out all day or do you
like to if there's a town right there I
like to walk around but I don't like to
no I don't like to be out I like to hang
out in the hotel you like to stay in the
room a lot you no not in the room but
you just walk around the hotel you like
that yeah if it's a nice Spa it's fun
yeah like being on a vacation I know
yeah I well cuz I used to say oh you
know going on the road it's like a it's
like a mini vacation but now I realize
that it's not true because the whole day
you're kind of consumed with what the
hour is going to be at that time right
so you're not really relaxing you don't
relax but it is kind of a good time to
do writing and try to figure out the
organization of it all right right yeah
I try I try but I I I occupy myself too
much I get I just always have to be out
of the room I wake up I Occupy Wall
Street I uh I have oh look this the
sweater the coffee stained dried that's
what good good technology with Lulu you
look see doesn't stain it's great what
do you
think unless you said I wouldn't even
know it exist you know what else is
making a big comeback you ready for this
carart carart making a huge comeback I
went to the carart store in Detroit
shout out Ryan from the card store gave
me 75% discount I bought my little one
pink overalls and then I bought myself a
jean jacket Big Discount Car heart's
coming back and he said he said the car
heart's coming back and it's it's now
everybody's wearing car heart but nobody
knows how to work with tools that's a
good point yeah everyone's got the
carart stuff on nobody knows how to even
light up a freaking chainsaw interesting
mind right but it is but that's what
happens did you want to tell the Dela
story is that for air I want to I want
to say it's a funny story but I just
think you know what what the goals are I
can't I'll tell Colin off air because it
is a funny story I wish that we could
but I also had another funny story too
on uh Chrissy chos that we had to cut
because it was it was inside info it was
inside info uh story and then I asked
the guy I asked the guy who I told the
story about I said can I say this and he
goes let me tell you something no and
here's why and I'll tell you off the air
oh no it's like a mob thing yeah hey
unbelievable which one of my friends is
uh does mafia movies I like this you
like that hey when we do the uh I look
like I'm having an active stroke that
picture when we do the yeah that is a
strange picture it doesn't look like you
but looks like s whoever did that is a
fan of
s the um when we do the uh Ridgewood uh
block by block I can't wait well you're
saying that but just think of all the
stories you won't be able to tell
because of mob related or you know let's
face it rosinski you can't make jokes
about rosinski well rosinski didn't grow
up in Richard he grew up in Ozone Park
if you want to do a block by Block in
oone park we'll do that 1001 Avenue you
won't be able to do it I'll have to do
with rosinski yeah but I'll be there you
know just kind of Link lingering yeah
what about uh in O par the uh I'll do a
blackb with patty patty flyballs well
then we got to go to Massi and Middle
Village Middle Village I meant to say
he's in Middle Village yeah speaking of
uh ozan Park did you see get Gotti on
Netflix the three episodes no get Gotti
is one of the best Gotti uh
documentaries John Gotti documentaries
because a lot of time you know we've
seen the stories we've heard know
castalano whack castalano we know all
that but this one this one get Gotti
this this um point of view of this
documentary is about um the struggle of
trying to C salano uh the building's
testing alarms today oh good perfect for
a podcast in some ways it's good it let
people realize it's live it's it's not
live
AI they the fans won't even hear
probably won't even okay so with geani
they I mean this is
sick yeah we know with with get Gotti
they um this this documentary is about
the FBI CIA and the I think like the New
York State detectives department or
something were how they they all were
trying to investigate God and because
each one of them was trying to get the
credit because it was like a ground
breaking case for them what they did is
they let Gotti slip away each time
because they were rather than working
together they will work at separate but
it's end of Brooklyn don't forget about
the movie
end that's the subplot is all the
different agencies I know go ahead but
it's pretty funny this this one this
this uh prosecutor I think her name is
jackalone she's how about this ready for
this ter imagine this I know this so you
know the story so they literally this is
one little spoiler here but they're
they're in court God's in court imagine
this you're John Gotti okay the infamous
John Gotti and then one of his best
friends for 20 years Willie Boy Johnson
was a rat was an informant for her Jack
colone nobody knew that nobody knew that
and when you well it wasn't for her it
was for the other right but it was her
it was her was like yeah agency she
could de right she she had the access to
the information so in court in front of
everybody doesn't even tell him doesn't
even tell her peers she just outs Willie
Boy Johnson in front of John Gotti yep
like basically killed him in front and
then they said you know to her in the
interview they were like wouldn't you um
like you know didn't you know that was
going to that was going to get him
killed she's like well he was leading a
certain life he was going to die anyway
I'm like no that's almost like murder
you should be charged murder and then
they shot Willie Boy Johnson three or
four days later they shot him five
couple years later oh a couple years
later yeah Oh I thought it was right
after that no they waited yeah they shot
him and they left him dead in his
driveway which in the mafia you kill
somebody in front of their house in
front of their wife and kids is a big
sign of disrespect and everybody knew
John Gotti did it like everybody knew
and so they kill him like they left him
his body out 20 minutes later they're
they're at John God's house the news and
they go what do you have to say did you
you know uh Willie Boy Johnson died and
he goes whoa I didn't hear and then they
were like oh and he goes uh do you have
a comment he goes we all got to go
sometime remember and then walked away
and just sat in the car and I was like
wow that's how that's how powerful he
was back then where it was like
everybody knew you had something to do
with it but they could do nothing CU you
kept getting away well that's a guy they
should have of you the guy the first
case when he first got famous there was
a guy named Roman in your neighborhood
maybe you'll have to save that for the
Ridgewood block block well but a guy a
big Polish guy that lived around
Ridgewood and mpth and his double park
car oh obviously had a temper and he
smashing the horn and Gotti and his guys
come out smack him he had $400 in his
pocket pulled his money out took his
money and then he went to court in the
famous game I forgotti that was what the
post said yes because they go did you
you you prose because he had them
arrested and he didn't realize somebody
goes this John Gotti yeah that they they
talk about that in the documentary I
forgot I didn't realize that it was uh
Ridgewood mmith guy yeah it was right it
was a Polish guy from maybe it was
Greenpoint it was one of those bars you
know now I know Gary Veer had a stance
on this doc because he said he can't
watch a documentary that has
reenactments at all why I don't know he
and this had reenactments I guess so no
I don't think this one had um maybe it
had a couple I'm pretty sure he was
talking about this one but I don't know
it was interesting he hates reenactments
I feel like um well most reenactments
are badly done what it is so instead of
complaining get why doesn't Gary
do I hate to say another one of my show
ideas was the that's why so M at Gary
his reenactments it had reenactments but
it's filming scenes for example you
could say Good Fellas is a reenactment
interesting you could what does Gary V
have to say about that nothing
nothing yeah I'll tell you where his
good reenactments Colonial Williamsburg
that's a nice
trip
that's I went there once I did a show
there Mary College what about our idea
that we were supposed to go do shows
around different Civil War battles we
supposed to be on the col chy Civil War
tour that's a good idea especially
nowadays we told our guy burtz and then
what do we get phomen we got nothing
that's a good idea especially now with
the Civil Wars coming let's do it the
Civil War you have time when does your
tour end I'm ready December 10th okay I
I'm going to end sometime in February oh
time well I'm trying to get I'm ready
all right Civil War reenactments I like
it all right maybe I should keep the
beard for the Civil War I think I like
that Jeb Stewart oh Jeb Stewart you have
those little beards yes yeah little
little cute little beards they all kept
those beards did you have breakfast yet
no I didn't what are you GNA go with
today I don't know maybe I'll go to Ole
and Ste I say anybody been in lately and
they be like yeah one guy came in he was
out for number
one
all right I got to uh yeah I think I'm
I'm I I didn't eat now let me ask you
something a while down
here do you take the E train yes to
World Trade Center that's all I wanted
to know Long Island Railroad transfer a
pen to the e or I could take the E the
whole way that's what I'm saying the E
is right downstairs yes the only problem
with the E is as it's the last stop so
it's the homeless train because
sometimes you get on like I'll get on 6
:30 in the morning or something and the
all the homeless they they won't be
bothered down here and I'll get in the
car and there'll be five homeless people
sleeping and three of them just smell
terrible you know smell horrific why do
you take the E so early in the morning
what what is your early morning train if
I have business Uptown or something I
have to do I don't know you got business
that early Uptown sometimes yeah what
kind of business Uptown that early I
don't know doctors or you know Jim and
Sam
occasionally Jim and Sam you know Jim
and Sam I I I would like to do Jim and
salmon see it was such a chore to get to
serus XM in the morning from Staten
Island but now that I'm living much
closer I'd like to do more serious XM
stuff it's going to be a breeze for you
because you can literally you don't have
to leave underground you get off it's
4750 Rockefeller Plaza walk right
upstairs beautiful perfect get right the
only time I got to walk out is to walk
to the E
train what yeah that's true how about
this now tell me S your West forth tell
me if if if if you if you would get
creeped out by this as well when I leave
my building where I live now sometimes I
go I leave very early sometimes at 5:00
in the morning I try to get work out
before the kids wake up and when I walk
out of my building I turn left 5:30 5:00
a.m. I I leave it's early cuz the only
way I can get any reading done or
exercise done sometimes is before the
children wake up you just have to do it
right so so I walk past this one spot
where it was famous because it was where
Sam Son of Sam killed one of his first
victims Andor what's her name yeah he
shot her through a through a textbook
yeah and young and I and every time I
walk past it I like I I get creeped out
and now what I've been doing is I've
been not walking past that spot I've
been crossing the street and then
Crossing back and is that something am I
being a little [__] for that or would
you do the same thing I mean uh I mean
son of Sam's locked up you don't have to
worry about that and you have the uh
maybe it's because of that third hand
connection with the Son of Sam that you
have yes that's true Maybe
some psychic energy coming in when
you're home alone can do you sleep with
all the lights off or does it creep you
out no I like to have a light on because
also you bump into [__] but I don't like
sleep it's too dark what about in a
hotel room will you have a TV on at
least you yeah I always have a light on
I always have like the bathroom light on
or something like that but will you will
you turn the TV off but the truth is you
shouldn't if you're really worried about
being killed in your sleep you should
have the lights off because then you and
the killer are equal if you're asleep
and lights on they can see you right so
really the smart move is have all the
lights off and sleep under the bed
anytime we would hear a noise in our
Staten Island House it would be Jasmine
who would go down and check well I
always Jen thinks I'm crazy because I
always have a giant I have a a giant
butcher knife and Afghan knife and a
hatchet by the bed so then she's like
why do you always have those I go just
CU you never know and then one time at
2: in the morning our bell rang and our
door is right there next to it I saw it
was in your apartment and right so I and
that door is kind of shaky anyway I
opened the door with the knife like this
it was a delivery guy some came in the
wrong apartment he's
like at 2 am. food delivery yeah
somebody's yeah you a lot of kids in a
abild they at 2 am. they're all stoned
and then uh he's delivered at 2 a.m.
good
night yeah are you actually
superstitious about anything
Superstition or like have rituals yeah
well before the well everybody says I I
didn't even notice it by myself but I
walk I I don't hit cracks I try to walk
in the street something like that except
when we're doing block by block then it
all goes away but otherwise if more by
myself I'm always trying not to hit the
cracks I never even think about it but
I'm always trying to step in the and I
count them the whole time right that's
OCD is not supersti I do you still walk
with your keys in your hands like
Wolverine when no but I'm always you
know what I mean like sometimes if I if
I there's times I walk around if I have
like a athletic bag I will put a knife
in there sometimes I'm fine just as a
weapon just to have it just to have it
just in case yeah why not why not you
because you never know when shit's about
to knife combat seems strenuous it does
but if you're in the train and you're
like please just take the W just let me
leave my my hoodie I just need
to sa him well how about Halloween I was
doing trick-or-treating the other day
yeah we went trick-or-treating the whole
the whole day me and this and you know
my kids and this other couple their kids
and I'm talking to the guy we've been
with each other for three and a half
hours four hours already he goes uh I
was like man there's so many people out
like I was like you know if somebody
wanted to pop off right now ter or
something like that he goes he goes well
yeah that's why I have my gun on me I
said you've had a gun on you this whole
time it goes the whole time I don't
leave my house without my gun I was like
wow you would walk past this guy never
realized he has a freaking gun on him
and he's a law enforcement guy X yeah
well retired right so he has the gun
because law enforcement they're allowed
required to carry the gun the rest of
their life yeah yeah I think this I
think it's legally that supposed to yeah
because if God forbid you lost your gun
and you have so made so many guyss you
arrested I had a friend I remember tell
in Florida and he's like we talk about
that and he goes I can't really walk
around relax by the that Beach one ey
goes you know many people I arrested
this he goes the guys that got out they
were in for 12 years they just hate you
they hate me you know he goes they'll
kill me just cuz I put them in jail
right yeah I know I think about that but
that's why how many how many audience
members you crowdwork and
insulted a few oh my God this is our new
movie crowd work a guy that does
crowdwork insults people and then one of
them holds a grudge and kills them and
kills them yeah or or or like that movie
The Fan with Robert dairo how when he
winds up killing uh uh tries to kill um
the San Wesley Snipes maybe that's what
it is I'm like a we got like a derange
fan and I'm Wesley Snipes let me ask you
this did you really feel compelled to
rewrite in public on the podcast my [__]
new original idea not only putting it
back to an already done idea but then
going maybe that's what it
is yeah maybe or maybe the original idea
I just came up with maybe that's what it
is what do you think we're in a goddamn
pitch meeting you're the executive what
if it's dairo and Wesley Snipes thank
you well this is the point this is the
problem with podcasting we talk too much
what's that this the problem somebody
going to steal this idea now and going
redo it and they're going to take both
of it they're going to take my brilliant
original idea and steal the template AI
of that screenplay the fan and rewrite
it and make it a big hit yep who who's
going to play that crowd comedian not
you m wife yes he deserves it Sam Marl
Hulu presents Sam Marl Matt R and tayl
Tomlinson in the crowd
worker love it go see him tomorrow in
Florida CQ baby I'm not in Florida
tomorrow I'm in Vegas Vegas tomorrow
Florida the following Treasure Island go
see me then see tin and Amy and then see
Nate Bazi all in one night
stagger it 20 minutes each show that's
all you got to do Treasure Island now do
you like that are you looking forward to
that do you like their hotel what Hotel
Treasure Island yeah I haven't been to
Treasure Island hotel the last time
youve been in Las Vegas what's that the
last time you might have been in Las
Vegas you and I when you spun the uh the
wheel for the Vegas Knights yes and they
won that night that's right and we you
and I wore the same shirt it was very
embarrassing on morning radio I mean a
morning we did a comedy sell yes have
you been back there and was with us too
yes uh tayor Tomlin Taylor Tomlinson
which and you know what and I know now
Taylor Tomlinson now cuz remember she
wouldn't everybody else was hanging out
having breakfast but she was doing her
own thing and everyone was like who she
is well now I know who she is she's this
late night host of CBS show because she
was like I'm not going to get polluted
with your guys dumb ideas I'm doing my
own thing and she's a star now and we're
just here what the hell are you talking
about this is ridiculous
um who else was with us Mike veon
remember he was six had a stomach virus
he said oh it's from the vegetables I
said it's from the
steroids Mike Cannon what you think
makes me older the white beard or that
laugh I just gave
was Mike Cannon Mike Cannon was there
Liz Liz of course Liz furiati the best
yeah and it was a good show and it was a
great show although honestly Vegas and
me you know I literally write material
for them and they're still like yeah
they can take me and leave me Vegas
infuriates me yeah I think cuz Vegas is
they're not really in the mood to
they're they're doing other things in
Vegas what's the best what I think the
best comedy town is Boston in the mood
to what they're in the mood to gamble
and fornicate I'm making jokes about
gambling they don't like it they don't
want to because what if some of them
just lost their money but I'm not
mocking them it's not my crowd worker
Marina how about that wait
that's that's where it happens we're in
Vegas and somebody crowd works and mocks
a guy who just lost money and then they
this is the plot then he has motivation
so the fans are like I hate him he's a
psycho but when you lose money it hurts
right because they made fun of him and
they didn't even realize a good plot
like the Robie Williams movie which one
the car car sales the one know where he
photographs everybody oh yes one hour
photo what one hour photo what does that
have to do with it I don't know I just
wanted to make some type of movie
reference against back on the Wesley
Snipes joke but I I didn't you know that
wasn't a bit of a movie I Robin will put
out great movies hook you know
amazing yeah there also a lot of bad
ones I'll be in Florida tomorrow Daniel
Beach oh Daniel Beach I got two shows
tomorrow two show you up by the highight
place I went to Daniel highight once
what's Daniel Highline yeah Daniel highi
highi what is that highi you know the
game highi they play that Portuguese
like Basque game you you guys never
heard of that game higher i j i j a i a
l a i I only play ma no no it's a g it's
like a that game J highi people bet on
it oh okay and you and you and you play
it in daa and people B bet on it all the
time how'd you do it was funny I didn't
play I was just there losing money but
then I was with my friend Mike and we
met this kid gypsy Eric was a gypsy that
Mike knew and we're talking to him and
mik goes yeah these guys they drive
around then they run into they have this
old Mercedes meres and they run into
people's Mercedes and they go oh my God
you ruined my Mercedes and they make
people pay them and I go oh that's crazy
with Gypsy Eric I met him literally that
night for two seconds two years later
I'm in LA on the other side of the
country I'm pulling into my dry cleaner
and just I see a crash with a Mercedes
and out of the car comes Gypsy
Eric I go hey he's like hey like trying
not to talk to me he's trying to do
business right in a weird coincidence
Gypsy Eric not to be used with well
we'll bleep that out
right yeah sure I mean know I was saying
I was saying it was in the block by
block here's a new plot it's not in the
block by block episode I think here's
the new plot oh that whole thing was out
ah okay so got to edit that out reason
we talking about it now now it's going
to edit out my whole boring gyps Eric
Story and what's now the new plot let's
say a guy like homeless once you dead
how does he kill you you could go to
jail jail if you poison him if you shoot
him you go to jail if you push him on a
window so a podcast producer killing the
host yes that's good and he does it by
not editing out something like that and
then they have a whole trial like did
you know like is that murder if he
didn't edit out that thing and you got
murdered ah interesting I like that
that's a I like that finally I came up
with something he's not [__]
rearranging this whole podcast if anyone
has the trouble to look at the whole
thing is me out good ideas and you going
and just making this face at me like and
then just changing the subject which is
fine I get it you know you get to a
certain age the wisdom in the white beer
the white
beer all right let's go get a tea I owe
you one
tea te this cheap son of [__] was
talking about I can't wait to indulge in
a giant lunch a Sumptuous feast and he's
like all right we'll get you a tea we'll
get you a tea I got a haircut I gotta go
I got where he go Manhattan no queens
where the uh uh your old place R it's
he's a um Israeli Barber actually oh but
just to shape up I got to grow my hair
out got a big movie oh that's right
though yeah I got to grow my hair out
wait that's when I'll have to take over
the podcast but not only stay on vessie
Street none of it moves to Jo de
roses what are you going to do who's
going to replace for two months you just
go through telling the fans you know
podcast people rely on see it every week
and they like by the way going home
movie see you guys in about 3 months
whatever whatever no I mean we'll we'll
have to uh we'll Bank the episodes
that's going to be crazy maybe you can
do them on the set I don't know no you
got but if they film it all the way
across the country oh they going to film
it maybe Vancouver oh I would like for
it to be in New York and New Jersey that
would be that would be great but I have
no pull no and you know what little time
Bo from the family you're like you you
you and Jazz are like uh David Beckham
and Posh yes we've been compared to that
see yeah yes the Puerto Rican Spice Girl
did you watch that documentary David
Beckham and Posh her name would be adobo
was good right really good I thought it
was better than Getti what's love they
each they really did here's the thing
about Beckham she's right Beckham was
this handsome guy he
literally was such a good guy that he
you know girls were throwing themselves
at him his whole life he cheated once
and you could see it was like he was
traumatized by it it's what every girl
wants
yeah but now they're together still
beautiful that's it all right
Colin I I just I don't understand even
that last moment I really don't
understand you know what I'm going to O
and Stein I'm just going to sit in the
window and watch you get your hair watch
you go to the E
train and be like man that guy needs a
haircut all right see you later
bye uh don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey babe